bonjour je suis hespel est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du soul
is
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin à la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
et comme disait bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie tu ne seras avoué car la quête
du graal trouver la chaussure parfait en
chaume ou sur son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à nos
gens aujourd'hui dans histoire de
souliers la pote
d'où vient-elle comment apporter des
professionnels de la mode et de la
confection de chaussures vous
expliquions son histoire saviez vous par
exemple que l'on avait retrouvé des
représentations de botte dans le qu'un
tueur rupestres vous découvrirez ensuite
quelles sont les tendances du moment
nos professionnels vous aiguilleront
avec leurs conseils shopping
ils vous apprendront également ce qu'il
faut éviter à tout prix enfin nous vous
présenterons des modèles de vote
complètement extravagant que vous n'avez
probablement jamais vu et qui ont fait
fureur dans le milieu de la haute
couture et du design mais tout d'abord
allons voir ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
paris c'est au coeur de la capitale de
la mode que nous sommes allés enquêter
pour savoir ce que vous pensiez de la
botte
alors mesdames votre avis
j'aime me battre parce qu'elles sont
femmes et que je peux les portables avec
tous ces
pratique qu'autre chose même en soirée
les bottes hiver ça passe bien et les
chaussures ouvertes l'été ou dans les
soirées un peu plus classe une fois
j'avais mis des dalons super haut de 15
cm et je me suis pris un trottoir et je
suis tombé et a effectivement un bide
notamment qui s'est cassé leur tour mag
mais ça je pense que c'est vraiment
arrivé après non c'est pas vous et ben
moi ouais voilà notre que moi je porte
pas de talons des six mois j'en porte un
jour chez les bleus est par exemple ses
bottes la ja une dame qui m'a arrêté
dans la rue pour me demander mais je
devais acheter parce qu'elle les
trouvait très bien et ce truc que je te
payer 5 euros offre est pris donc
qu'elle était un petit peu une arme
[Musique]
elle préserve le pied les coûts les
salissures et de l'humidité
elle développe les balades sous la pluie
en bretagne les promenades à cheval mais
aussi les gens ultra sexy les héroïnes
des années 70 mais le port de la boîte
par les femmes est relativement
restreint
avant de devenir la botte secrète des
sommes en jeu voyons comment la botte a
été créé
qu'est ce que la botte vous évoque
bon bah juliette je te laisse l'honneur
de réponse à demi-mot que rien pas grand
chose non plus la botte ça va être la
botte cavalière pour tous les jours pour
aller marcher dans la forêt pour aller
se promener pour quand il pleut fort
pour quand images la botte fourrée mais
voilà pas de grand enthousiasme sur la
botte chez nous d'accord donc la botte
ne fait pas partie de vos modèles
fétiches pas trop non
on va passer de la bottine avec
cuissardes pour quelle raison parce que
ces mines 1 et ça casse le mollet
salaire juste en dessous du genou quand
on a le jeu mot un peu fort
malheureusement fait pas pitié du rec
toi même si complexes de jeu nous voilà
c'est pas facile la botte et qu'est ce
que vous pensez du retour de la mode des
bottes en caoutchouc
moi ça me fait beaucoup rire voilà il y
en a plein de plein de couleurs quand il
pleut le temps est triste et du coup
c'est rigolo de voir toutes ces femmes
avec des battes de toutes les couleurs
ça et gagnent un peu les rues paul
abbott n'ont évoqué l'année
can you
[Musique]
la botte est un accessoire je pense
aussi indispensable peut-être un peu
moins que la low boots mais lorsqu il
fait vraiment froid
les femmes aiment est en bottes malgré
tout parce qu'elles sont quand même
protéger contre le froid et l'humidité
bien évidemment alors comment choisir
idéalement sa paire de bottes
déjà il faut voir le mollet delà de la
cliente
on peut pas vendre n'importe quoi à
n'importe qui donc nous nous avons des
bottes avec des largeurs différentes et
des longueurs aussi différente de façon
à ne pas casser la silhouette de la
cliente
c'est hyper important le style de
l'hiver 2013 pour la botte bon c'est
déjà en numéro 1 le noir il faut avoir
dans sa garde-robe idéalement toujours
une boîte noire avec un petit talon et
même un talon même compenser la botte
compensées qui est très très confortable
avec une semelle souple un bloc souple
de façon à accompagner
idéalement le parent de la cliente sans
fatigue
[Musique]
oh
il est très difficile de dire qui de la
botte de la sandale et la chaussure la
plus ancienne
ces deux types de chaussures semble
avoir été créé au même moment mais dans
des contextes et des modes de vie
différents
quoi qu'il en soit les peintures
rupestres les plus anciennes que l'on
ait pu retrouver montre des bottes fait
de fourrure et de pau il y à plus de 13
mille ans
la botte avait à l'origine une fonction
protectrice très vite
seuls les hommes portait des bottes
confiné un simple but fonctionnel puis
le port des bottes par les femmes
étaient tolérés pour la pratique
exclusive de l'équitation
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'en 1830 que les femmes ont
commencé à porter des bottes au
quotidien leur vocation était de faire
paraître le pied plus petit et de
dissimuler le pied et la cheville pour
les préserver de toute tentation
masculine pousseront à un pied dissimulé
et engoncé dans une pièce et 3 de cuir
n'a jamais autant réveiller les sens
c'est le principe même de la suggestion
[Musique]
puis lors de la révolution industrielle
les bottes deviennent plus accessibles
et représente le symbole d'une égalité
entre les sexes mais surtout les classes
sociales
mais ce n'est qu'au xxème siècle que les
bots commence à être l'accessoire de
mode que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
[Musique]
les formes se développent les matériaux
s'enrichissent et le tableau
s'encanaille pour donner le pas à une
allure qui se veut de plus en plus
libéré début du xxième siècle la botte
se veut aussi masculine que féminine
[Musique]
pour moi la bottine et les low boots
sont devenus incontournables avec la
grande vague marais du cageot chic
d'aucune logo une low boots et moi
structurantes et structures avec une
botte ac - couvrante donc les filles
retrouvent une certaine liberté dans une
beauté nude louboutin qu'elle rompt pas
forcément dans une botte
que la botte vous évoque
disons que la botte aujourd'hui on a
plusieurs tendances de vote
on a serré à la fois la botte très
féminine avec une tige à ses hôtes un
talon pas trop faim puisque vraiment
c'est la botte de tous les jours et puis
on travaille aussi nous avec les patins
intérieur donc là on le voit pas mais il
ya quand même un léger pâte intérieur
qui la rend encore plus confortable
toujours des matières très très très
noble mais aujourd'hui ce qui prend un
peu le pas sur la mode donc déjà allé
quand même assez concurrencée par la low
boots parce que finalement c'est un peu
de l'âme usage bien que sur avec une
robe religieux
la boîte est plus joli mais ce qu'on a
beaucoup depuis maintenant deux saisons
c'est vraiment le style biker ce style
biker avec donc moins de finale c'est
vrai donc avec une semaine 30 et avec un
cuir grainé avec un côté parfois sur
scène sinon mais parfois avec un côté
patiner vintage des clous avec des
choses quand même qu'ils sont un peu
plus forte au niveau du style
aujourd'hui a vraiment sa légitimité
on les voit de plus en plus et puis
c'est vraiment une tendance qui se
conçoit chez à la fois les plus grands
et puis en même temps aussi on est on
les remarque chez les détaillants
vraiment enfin dans n'importe quel but
rueront on trouve aujourd'hui vraiment
des bikers un peu partout pourquoi parce
que on a envie peut-être deux choses
voilà un petit peu plus confortable et
fut même avec un look un petit peu plus
fort
donc c'est un peu dans l'esprit actuel
c'est vraiment ça qui va prendre le pas
par rapport à des modèles
c'est vrai un petit peu plus classique
ou dans la des bottes dont on joue on
aime bien jouer sur les matières avec
vraiment voilà des cuirassés original la
cnce et un échantillon donc cet ancien
soudeur très forte mais on aime bien
aussi jouer
bon voilà avec ces matières la bon pour
ne pas toujours retomber sur les mêmes
histoires et sur les mêmes produits
donc aujourd'hui la botte c'est
évidemment une inconditionnelle dans la
dans la garde-robe mai
voilà c'est en train de se faire
grignoter par des choses un peu plus
pour soi on va dire par des choses un
petit peu plus ou moins habillées donc
sa volaille choses et je pense que ce
sera encore cette saison une de nos
meilleures ventes
ce sera là biker donc la botte dès lors
quels héraults bilité elle reste
toujours une question danse oui la botte
est un inconditionnel
déjà il ya plusieurs auteurs de la botte
on peut la prendre à la fois plaque me
la prendre avec un talon de 2,7 cm on
peut la prendre avec un talon 10 donc à
chaque fois c'est toujours des styles
des tenues adaptées c'est toujours des
styles différents
donc la botte l'avantagé que suivant la
matière suivant la semelle de compenser
intérieur ou pas le patin pas de patin
ça donne à chaque fois une image suivant
la manière dont on la porte
et puis ça peut avoir aussi parce que
j'en reviens toujours à ça a un côté un
peu un peu sexy lorsque la tige et plus
haute lorsque talon est plus fin mais
bon on peut pas faire n'importe quoi non
plus parce que c'est vite ça peut virer
au vulgaire mais voilà je pense que la
botte ce sera encore un des succès de
l'hiver parce que c'est quelque chose
finalement on arrive à à pérenniser
aujourd'hui on on essaye chaque saison
quand même sur des modèles assez
classique puisque nous on est à la
pointe mais on reste quand même très
commercial on essaye voilà d'avoir cette
chance là en ayant des des bottes qui
peuvent être soit fou ray soit compensé
en essayant vraiment de mélanger les
matières d'autres c'est voilà notre
objectif c'est vraiment d'essayer de
revisiter des classiques en essayant de
mixer les matières les couleurs et puis
les talons donc voilà c'est ce qu'on
essaye de faire et puis je vous dirai si
cette saison s'est bien passé
toi
[Musique]
quelle femme ne peut être pas une paire
de bottes dans son dressing
la paire de bottes et le symbole des
princes charmants dans les contes de
fées mais surtout la paire de chaussures
des femmes sûres d'elles les bottes sont
une arme de séduction mais elles sont
aussi un signe et très fonctionnel pour
pratiquer l'équitation pour se protéger
de la pluie
la botte est un type de chaussures
plutôt apprécié des créateurs de haute
couture et des designers surtout dans
les collections hivernales et il faut
bien avouer qu'en tant que chaussure la
plus grande après la cuissarde elle
recouvre une partie conséquente du corps
et offrent alors des possibilités de
création hors du commun
c'est pourquoi on constate que cette
chaussure est souvent considéré comme
une pièce de vêtement à part entière le
créateur controversé alexander mcqueen
réalise des bottes avec des matières
évoquant l'hiver ce modèle joue sur un
effet de rupture entre la fourrure
blanche et le pire lys noir chez dolce
gabbana on présente une botte à mi
chemin entre la chaussures et
chaussettes en laine joue ainsi sur les
matières et la confusion dans le même
esprit prada explore le contraste des
matières pour un modèle à première vue
assez sobre mais sortant de l'ordinaire
comme cette botte qui donne une
impression d'allier une marie jeanne et
un collant d'autre part chanel comme
givenchy décide de mélanger bottes et
guêtres proposons ainsi des modèles
tubulaire ou la tige descend sur le
talent
[Musique]
christian louboutin qu'on va lui
détourne les codes habituels de la botte
observant une découpe en forme des
escarpins en cuir verni noir
la chaussure est principalement
constituée de cuir couleur chair donnant
l'illusion que les coutures sont faites
dans la jambe
la créatrice ann demeulemeester propose
un modèle d'inspiration militaire mais
avec un détail qui sait se faire
remarquer une mèche en fourrure
semblable à un crin de cheval dans une
perspective beaucoup plus coloré manolo
conçoit des votes à ses ennemis tout en
jouant sur la géométrie et l'assemblage
des différentes formes
anastasia rabin s'intéresse au contraste
entre la douce de la laine de mouton et
les découpes acérées du talon ou là il
la tond deux créatrices finlandaise qui
allie forme ludique couleurs vives et
expérimentations structurelles
[Musique]
à kouba quatre hommes expérimentent de
nouvelles associations de matières
notamment avec du bois dans des formes
et des constructions innovantes
manou batista étudiants en design de
chaussures propose ce modèle
probablement inspiré de la combinaison
de l'héroïne du film kill bill
avec un talon plateforme imposant et
travailler parmi les modèles de chez
kobi levi designer connu pour ses
modèles originaux à tendance ludique et
inspirés du quotidien
on retiendra surtout ses bottes
symétrique que l'on a pu apercevoir dans
un clip de lady gaga
enfin rachel leclerc propose des bottes
fait d'empiècements de couleurs
différentes pour des modèles très
colorés pour une allure qui n'est pas
parfois sans rappeler les bottes de
cowboy
[Musique]
alors mon petit conseils shopping pour
bien choisir sa botte
donc je n'en porte pas aujourd'hui car
je suis petit et oui mesdames
ça me coupe le mollet et s'arrêterait si
mes jambes petit problème donc je reste
sur des talons aiguilles pour bien
choisir sa botte mieux vaut partir sur
une cavalière
donc du coup la cordée soit avec un
petit short en jean un petit peu brute
et c'est pour retrouver un peu le côté
masculin et ont joué avec peut-être une
chemise assez strictes nous et au niveau
au niveau de la taille pour retrouver ce
côté assez féminin voilà allier les deux
c'est vrai que ça donne un côté sexy
masculin est très sympa et assez
novateur pour le coup ou sinon alliés
pour cet hiver des bottes un peu santiag
avec un jean slim une petite une petite
veste un peu cuir pour retrouver un peu
le côté motards et c'était assez sympa
aussi de jouer sur ce côté là ou alors
aller un peu plus loin une petite robe
en dentelle assez cru y voir avec des
encore des cavalières avec une tonalité
assez foncée donc un bon marron et une
petite une petite veste en jeans jouera
sur un côté encore masculin mais féminin
est aussi un côté rétro et actuel assez
sympa accordé
mon conseil shopping sur la botte s'est
idéalement d'avoir si possible de très
jolies jambes mais avec un slim ou une
jupe c'est très joli
ok quand c'est chaud pin sur la botte
assurez-vous que ça suive les courbes de
vos jambes que ça colle à vos jambes que
c'est que ça vous met en valeur
quel est votre conseil look pour la
botte pour moi c'est l'un des skis et le
plus beau dans la botte c'est vraiment
quand on voit la tige donc évidemment
tenues habillées ou pas mais voilà je
trouve que le meilleur moyen de voir
cette boîte là c'est quand elle est
forte avec quelque chose de cours un
pantalon ça a beaucoup moins de cendres
ces cours mais voilà c'est vraiment un
modèle qui se porte
bon assez facilement et puis bon et puis
tu es dans vraiment dans la tendance
donc récapitulons pour être au top de la
tendance avec vos bottes mesdames poser
les bottes cavalières sobre et bien
serré elles seront les amis de vos
tenues vintage ou couleurs un peu
passées les mélange des styles et des
époques
que vous soyez plutôt jupe strictes ou
plutôt veste en cuir les votes peuvent
vous aider a souligné un caractère bien
trempé al'inverse éviter si vous êtes
petit dissimuler vos pieds et vos jambes
par un même textile donnera une
impression de coupure genou les bottes
trop avec un pantalon
c'est une légère faute de goût les
bottes les plus hautes sont généralement
destinés à des gens venus ils ont
réservé les plus basses obtenu plus
couverte la botte est un des codes les
plus importants de la féminité au même
titre que la petite robe noire et le
rouge à lèvres une paire de bottes en
cuir noir est un indispensable à
posséder dans son placard à chaussures
de jolies bottes camel donneront un air
délicieusement vintage avoue tenu à
porter sur vos jeans ou encore avec une
jupe midi c'est à dire longueur au genou
je vous conseille de jouer à 100%
l'inspiration seventies à déconseiller
cependant les bottes blanches qui ne
vont à personne et les coloris
fantaisiste que vous regretterez très
rapidement d'avoir acheté miser plutôt
sur des valeurs sûres telles que le noir
le marron ou le camel mais il existe
bien d'autres modèles de bottes qui nous
seront utiles en hiver citons par
exemple les fameuses bottes australienne
en mouton retourné elles garantissent
une température intérieure constante de
22 degrés quelle que soit la saison
mais par contre ses bottes doivent
impérativement éviter la pluie
à très bientôt pour la suite d'histoires
de souliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]